نجاح خوارزمية VQE يعتمد بشكل كبير
على الحالة والـ circuit
التي نختار البدء بها
أنا Victoria Lipinska وفي هذا الفيديو
سنستكشف الخيارات
المتاحة لنا في تصميمها
لنلقِ نظرة أقرب
على جميع العناصر
الموجودة في كل تشغيل للجزء الكمي
من VQE
نبدأ بالحالة المرجعية
التي تُسمى أحياناً الحالة الابتدائية
نمرر الحالة المرجعية
عبر circuit ذات معاملات تُسمى
الشكل التغايري
مع اختيار ابتدائي للمعاملات
ونقيس الحالة
في أساس الهاملتوني
بعد تمريرها عبر الـ circuit
للحصول على القيمة المتوقعة الآن
سنمر على كل عنصر من هذه العناصر
بدءاً من الحالة المرجعية
الاختيار النموذجي للحالة المرجعية
هو حالة الصفر
أي الحالة التي يكون فيها الحاسوب
الكمي مُهيّأً بالفعل
لمسائل الكيمياء الكمية
يمكن أيضاً استخدام ما يُسمى
حالة Hartree-Fock
وهي ناتج طريقة
Hartree-Fock
باختصار نظرية Hartree-Fock
تعطي طريقة بسيطة لبناء
الحالة المرجعية عن طريق تقريب
الحالة الأرضية لنظام كمي
تجد دوراناً
ضمن فضاء الحالات
يُقلل طاقة الحالة الأرضية
أخيراً الحالة المرجعية
يمكن أن تكون أيضاً خاصة جداً بالمسألة
وقد ترغبون في اختيار
حالة مخصصة
في حالة معرفتكم بخصائص
نظامكم مثلاً التماثلات
أو عدد محدد من الإلكترونات
في الحالة يمكنكم استخدام ذلك
للحصول على تقارب أفضل لخوارزمية
VQE
اختيار حالة مرجعية جيدة
مهم للتقارب
الحالات المرجعية القريبة من
الحالة الأرضية
يمكن أن تجعل المسألة تتقارب
بسهولة وسرعة أكبر
بنفس الأهمية
اختيار قيم المعاملات الابتدائية
التي ندخلها في الشكل التغايري
لذلك حسب الحالة المرجعية
والمعاملات الابتدائية
قد نتقارب بسرعة أو ببطء
أو لا نتقارب على الإطلاق
لنلقِ نظرة على هذا الرسم البياني
ولأغراض التوضيح
لنتخيل أن فضاء المعاملات لدينا
له معامل واحد فقط
حالة مرجعية جيدة جداً
يمكن أن تسمح لك بالبدء قريباً جداً
من الحالة الأرضية النهائية
وعندها سيكون التقارب سريعاً
من ناحية أخرى إذا بدأت بعيداً جداً
عن الحالة الأرضية هنا
الحالة المرجعية
a ستضطر لعبور حاجز طاقة
عالٍ مما يؤدي إلى تقارب بطيء جداً
أو عدم تقارب على الإطلاق
سنناقش هذا بتعمق أكبر
في وحدة التحسين الكلاسيكي
في هذا المقرر
لننظر الآن في الـ circuit ذات المعاملات
التي تعمل على الحالة المرجعية أي
الشكل التغايري
عندما هذه الـ circuit أي
U من theta تعمل على الحالة المرجعية
تُنتج ما نسميه حالة تجريبية
psi من theta أو أحياناً ansatz
هذه حالة الـ ansatz هي التي
تُقاس بعد ذلك في أساس مناسب
للحصول على القيمة المتوقعة
للطاقة
الأشكال التغايرية
التي نناقشها هنا
مستوحاة من الكيمياء
لكن تذكروا أن هناك أيضاً تلك المستوحاة
من التعلم الآلي الكمي
وغيرها من خوارزميات
المدى القريب مثل خوارزميات
التحسين التقريبي الكمي
لنناقش
بعض الخيارات الشائعة لـ ansatz الكيمياء
العنقود المقترن الموحد أو UCC
هي الطريقة المقترحة أصلاً
في أول نشرة لـ VQE
وتُستخدم بشكل شائع في مسائل
الكيمياء الكمية
عادةً
عندما نعطي معاملات لحالة كمية
نتعامل مع عدد أسّي
من المعاملات
لكن لجعل circuits التحضير فعالة
نحتاج عدداً كثيري الحدود
من العمليات
وبالتالي عدداً كثيري الحدود
من المعاملات
UCC هو مثال على طريقة لتحضير
حالة تجريبية بمثل هذه الـ circuit
وهو مشتق من طريقة العنقود المقترن
التي هي المعيار الذهبي في
الكيمياء الكمية
الخيار الأكثر شيوعاً هو العنقود المقترن الموحد
للمفردات والمزدوجات
أي ansatz الـ UCCSD اختصاراً
لأن UCCSD مستوحى من التكوين الإلكتروني
المحدد لمسألة ما
نحتاج للتأكد من أن لدينا حالة
مرجعية تعكس النظام بشكل صحيح
هذه هي حالة Hartree-Fock
ansatz الـ UCCSD عادةً يعطي
تقريباً جيداً للحالة الأرضية
لأنه يلتقط الإثارات الإلكترونية
المفردة والمزدوجة في جزيء معين
عدد المعاملات في UCCSD يتناسب
تربيعياً مع عدد المدارات
المغزلية
UCCSD يمكن أن يكون مُكيّفاً جيداً
جداً لمسألة ما
لكن للأسف التناسب التربيعي
لا يزال يؤدي إلى circuits عميقة جداً
صعبة على الحواسيب الكمية
الحالية
لهذا اقترح باحثو IBM
منهجاً أكثر استدلالية
حيث يمكن تكييف الشكل التغايري
مع العتاد الأساسي
مما ينتج عنه circuit
قابلة للتنفيذ بكفاءة
أي أن الحالات التجريبية تُعطى معاملات
بواسطة gate كمية
ويتم تكييفها
مع الجهاز الفيزيائي المتاح
هذا منهج استدلالي جداً
وصديق للعتاد
بناءً على هذه الأمثلة لنلقِ نظرة
على طيف الإمكانيات
المتاحة لنا للتعبير عن
شكلنا التغايري
كثير من هذه
مُنفذة بالفعل في Qiskit
لذا أشجعكم على تجربتها بأنفسكم
لمعرفة أيها الأنسب
للمسألة التي تحاولون حلها
إذا نظرنا إلى الرسم البياني من جهة
لدينا الأشكال التغايرية
الاستدلالية جداً
حيث الخصوصية للمسألة منخفضة لكن
مصممة ليتم تنفيذها
على العتاد الحقيقي
وهي أيضاً عالية التعبير
بمعنى
أنه يمكن التعبير عن
حالات كمية كثيرة بها
لكن مشكلة قد تظهر
في المرحلة اللاحقة
من التحسين الكلاسيكي
هي مواجهة
ما يُسمى الهضبة القاحلة
التي سنناقشها في الوحدة التالية
من ناحية أخرى
لدينا العنقود المقترن الموحد عالي الخصوصية
للمسألة والذي يعمل
بامتياز في الكيمياء الكلاسيكية لكن
صعب التنفيذ على العتاد الكمي
بسبب أعماق الـ circuit الكبيرة
بشكل عام يمكن أن تكون الحسابات
أكثر نجاحاً إذا استطعتم
أولاً اختيار حالة مرجعية
ومجموعة ابتدائية من المعاملات
تُنشئ حالة ansatz
قريبة من الحالة الأرضية
وثانياً تجنب المعاملات غير الضرورية
هذه إما تُدخل
عمق circuit أكبر دون فائدة
أو تُنشئ فضاء معاملات أكبر
للبحث فيه مما يؤدي إلى هضاب
في التحسين الكلاسيكي
ما هي المعاملات الضرورية هو سؤال
خاص بالمسألة
يتطلب تفكيراً دقيقاً
لنتحدث عن أين يختبئ ضيف الشرف
الهاملتوني في كل هذا
كما تعلمنا في القسم السابق
الهاملتوني بعد ربط الـ qubit
يُمثَّل كمجموع
سلاسل مُرجَّحة من مؤثرات Pauli
في النهاية لكن
نريد حساب القيمة
المتوقعة للهاملتوني على حالة
الـ ansatz الناتجة من الشكل التغايري
لحسن الحظ ميكانيكا الكم
لطيفة وخطية
وهذا ما سنستخدمه
للحصول على القيمة المتوقعة
هكذا يعمل الأمر
نعلم أن الهاملتوني هو مجموع مُرجَّح
من Pauli
بسبب الخطية
القيمة المتوقعة للمجموع
تساوي مجموع القيم المتوقعة
لكل سلسلة Pauli
هذا رائع لأنه كما تعلمون بالفعل
القياس في أساس Pauli
بسيط مثل دوران
لأساس القياس المعتاد
بدلاً من قياس القيمة المتوقعة
على هذا الهاملتوني الضخم الممثل
كمجموع نحسب أولاً القيم المتوقعة
للحدود الفردية
ونجمع في النهاية
مع الأوزان المقابلة
لهذا في كثير من المراجع
سترون فقط دورانات qubit مفرد
بعد الـ ansatz
هذا ما يُنفذ الهاملتوني
في كل تشغيل للـ circuit
في الفيديو التالي
سنستكشف ما يحدث
خلال خطوة التحسين الكلاسيكي
أراكم هناك